Nicholas Burns is a former US ambassador
to NATO it was also Undersecretary of
State for political affairs during the
George W Bush administration he's a
professor to Harvard's Kennedy School he
joins us from Aspen Colorado good
morning Nick I assume that's been in the
morning is a pretty good place to be
it's a very nice place to be Charlie
thank you let me begin with this
sanctions worked against Iran in other
cases they do not work will they work
against North Korea and what
circumstances will allow them to work I
think it's unlikely charlie that the
sanctions will ultimately work meaning
that they would convince the North
Koreans to give up their nuclear weapons
I would say however this was a victory
for the Trump administration to see
these sanctions to convince China and
Russia to join but the North Koreans
prize above all else the possession of
these nuclear weapons they're testing
ballistic missiles they're modernizing
the weapons and for us for the Americans
the real danger is that within a couple
of years they could have the capacity to
have a nuclear weapon that could reach
the western part of the United States I
think the Trump administration is said
quite rightly that is an unacceptable
threat so I think what we're likely to
see is a continuing ratcheting up of
these sanctions by the US and the future
well will they work in the end I'm
afraid I don't think they will because I
don't think China will join them China
has the most leverage here they provide
most of the energy and most of the food
they of course just to the north of
North Korea and this was significant
they joined the sanctions significant
today that in Manila the Chinese foreign
minister was so tough on the North
Koreans but ultimately the Chinese don't
want to see very tough sanctions and
pressure on North Korea because I don't
want to see the regime collapse they
don't want to see refugees go into China
they don't want to see the Korean
Peninsula unified by the South Korean
government aligned with the United
States because that would be a victory
strategically for this long-running
competition between China and the United
States in Asia ambassador it seems like
we have the same conversation over and
over again about North Korea no good
options you can't bomb can't negotiate
you you can't really contain them so
what is the game changer here because
you hear Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson describing what he would like
to see is a precondition for talks well
Margaret I think you're right I mean the
north
Koreans are very different than the
Iranians you remember a couple of years
ago these tremendous financial and
economic oil and gas sanctions on Iran
Iran's a trading nation it wanted to be
connected economically to the rest of
the world so those sanctions work to
drive them to the negotiating table the
North Korea North Korea is a hermit
Kingdom they're isolated they don't
trade with many countries and I think
Kim jong-un this young leader of North
Korea believes that his possession of
nuclear weapons is his ultimate
protection against any foe most
especially the United States ambassador
they said the North Koreans did
yesterday we won't stop for anyone no
matter what they say does that mean
simply that we're gonna have to in the
end acquiesce to the idea that they have
nuclear weapons deliverable to the west
coast of the United States
I hope not and I think there's an
interim step here Charlie secretary
Tillerson has been hinting that we ought
to talk to the North Koreans not to be
nice to them but perhaps to negotiate
some kind of interim arrangement where
they might freeze or limit their testing
of nuclear weapons their development of
nuclear weapons and also of ICBMs
intercontinental ballistic missiles
that's a messy compromise but it'd be a
lot better than the current situation
they're not constrained right now and
they are racing towards a nuclear weapon
and that's a real threat to our country
ambassador Nicholas burns always good to
have you sir thank you thanks charlie